I watched uh the latest summoning salt
video that was about the Star Wars Lego
Star Wars and I sat there and I thought
hmm I won't watch an hour and a half
film but I'll watch an hour and a half
video about Lego speed runs and I
thought there's something wrong with me
no not that that there's something else
videos aren't good but I'm like what is
going on in my brain when I'm like it's
like fully produced The 100 million
dollar movie I'm like no but this Lego
Star Wars speedrun
yeah this is what I want to watch and I
I think it's I think there's just a
certain kind of commitment when it comes
to entertainment sometimes you want to
watch a highly produced like some like a
highly for sure produce piece of content
that you can really like invest yourself
in yeah
um but that takes a lot of like I I
think that takes a lot of emotional
commitment you know uh I agree uh and
that's why I think the Netflix logo is
too long I'm out but it's like five
seconds I'm like oh they're the opening
like genuine have you not done this
think about it so many times when that
Netflix intro plays I'm like no I'm
actually good and I Tab out I'm like
I think it gives me five seconds to like
realize I'm getting myself into
something and I'm like no does anyone
else do this I I hate how I know exactly
well you've opened something on Netflix
and that Netflix thing plays the the
it's like it's literally like five
seconds but that five seconds gives me
five seconds to be like actually I don't
yeah it's like yeah it's the five second
window of are you sure you want to come
here yeah genuinely because then you
have like again you have like another 10
15 seconds of long [ __ ] credits
playing it's just it's it's more like 10
seconds because it's the five seconds of
the dude and then it usually it's
followed by Netflix presents yeah it's
just long enough and it makes me it
makes me feel so serious the internet
has just hacked all of our minds because
this is yeah this they've just given us
pure ADHD at this point so the fact that
a 15 second intro of a logo can make us
rethink do I actually want to sit down
for this or do I just want to put on a
YouTube video with just I'm meeting I
could have watched three YouTube shorts
at that time yeah like that's like I
have found myself closing out of stuff a
lot more recently um but I did watch
something that was kind of interesting
watch the show on Netflix called uh
Kaleidoscope I don't know if you've seen
this no no so the concept of the show is
that essentially uh there's Nine
episodes if I recall correctly and uh
every Netflix account will be presented
to them in a different order
so you'll get a different episode order
depending on also it's kind of like love
death and robots and robots yeah uh oh
was it all different for everyone yeah
yeah yeah the episodes in that are all
randomized oh I didn't know that yeah
but
um the one thing with this is that it is
just it's not like an anthology series
it's a it's a like a story
but it's told out of order well it's
told whatever order you get given right
so it's a one connected story so it's
like a Tarantino yeah it's pretty odd
and um yeah yeah it's like it's like it
sounds it sounds okay it sounds
impossibly dumb yeah but the one thing
that I think they do is that I think the
last episode is always the same I think
okay
um so everything else this is a gimmick
it's a hundred percent it's a [ __ ]
gimmick it's a
relationship
so originally when Harry aired it was
aired in this there was there was this
huge debate when it aired right because
it was aired like like
um like the show out of order yeah where
every episode happened in a different
part of the timeline yeah and that was
the first season right
um and then everyone was just like oh my
God this is [ __ ] genius they're
letting us piece together the story by
telling it out of order we can piece
together the timeline ourselves yeah and
I'm [ __ ] convinced that they only did
that because the most interesting part
of the first Harry season were the first
six episodes and I think the producers
realized that because they realize holy
[ __ ] the last episode is is a [ __ ]
Christmas episode at least disappearance
it's basically a [ __ ] filler episode
we we can't end the season like this so
we have to like just piece The Ore piece
the episodes out of order to make it
seem interesting uh I mean it's I don't
know if it doesn't feel that way I was
very skeptical going into it because I
thought oh this is going to be Nine
episodes that feel completely
disconnected and then it's up to you to
put the pieces together yeah but it's
it's not really like that it was
actually pretty surprisingly not bad I
thought it was I again I was very
skeptical of the concept I was like this
[ __ ] dumb just tell me the story in
the order but depending on which order
you do get uh it can be a different
experience because essentially a lot of
the episodes cover like backstories and
certain information is kind of pieced
together or you're given certain like
you could figure something out way
sooner if you're given a certain episode
as opposed to something else this
literally just sounds like monogatari if
you didn't know the broadcasting order
if he just randomly picked seasons and
you're like oh okay I guess we're gonna
find out about this character that I
know nothing about it is kind of
interesting though I will say it's I
don't know if it's worth watching
because it did feel like after I got
halfway through it that okay it's like I
really did feel segmented yeah yeah but
I do think that if you've got certain
episodes it would feel like a completely
different as much as I realize it's like
a gimmick I do actually quite like
storytelling methods like that
especially if like the actual root story
yeah so it's interesting enough so it's
about uh a bank heist yeah and basically
there's uh there's multiple characters
and there's certain episodes like an
episode where they they do the heist
there's an episode after the heist yeah
uh and so that you know there's a chance
that you could get the after the heist
episode first which might be confusing
because the characters aren't really
introduced properly where there are
other episodes that do introduce
characters better so it's like that I
would say that probably is an order that
is probably best to watch it yeah but
you could get say like a Quentin
Tarantino experience if you had the
after Heist episode first yeah and then
you kind of piece everything together it
does work the thing about how you
describe me is that it to me like I love
the kind of Storytelling method where
it's not always presented to you in
chronological order but there has to be
some sort of intention with that you
know it needs to be done with purpose
like yeah the first example I think of
aside from Quentin Tarantino it's like
bacono right yeah bachano the story is
told in different time perspectives and
just not given to you in chronological
order but a lot of thoughts from the you
know creators was given into what piece
of information do we allow the audience
to see in order to piece things together
this just feels like uh we have a story
um and we're just gonna randomize it and
uh let the audience figure it out and
I'm just like that's that's just [ __ ]
lazy okay it just sounds like a V Source
episode of like so the story starts at
chapter one or does it I think I think
it was probably just a case of hey we
have the show how do we secure Netflix
funding Let's Have a Gimmick they can
Market yeah Fair it is interesting like
it's like it's kind of surprise it's
impressive that you could have all these
episodes kind of be mixed and it somehow
still makes sense yeah is it a good show
I'd say seven out of ten but the reviews
are pretty positive for it okay uh seven
eight out of tens like it's decent like
it's a fun gimmick the acting is kind of
um some of the characters act and you're
like what the [ __ ] yeah you'd rather
find you because they have like Gus Gus
from Breaking Bad isn't the main
character and he's pretty good because
he's good and everything yeah sure some
of the other actors you're like what
where are they fun does he play a bad
guy again no he plays a good guy oh my
God good depending on who you who you
ask I suppose well you know
there's there is no way he can play
listen I'm I'm of the mindset playing a
sauce again yeah Hey listen remember
we're following in the story I'm like
that's that's the good guy straight up I
don't care if he kills everyone we're
following him I I sympathize with him
yeah I go monkey brain that's also
definitely like a trend or a gimmick
recently as well isn't it that Netflix
is banking on with a lot of their like
fictional stories is that like you're
following the good guy or is he really
the good guy well I think it's just made
like that storytelling has become more
popular big shows like Breaking News
genuinely I was thinking about this the
other day
was you still watching a lot of Netflix
right uh how much documentaries I was
like does Netflix still make good stuff
the journal consensus is no yeah because
I remember because like I realized
recently I just how little I watch
Netflix in comparison to you know what
are you how much I used to watch it you
used it used to be Netflix had this show
that I really really wanted to watch or
like a few shows and then you'd find
some random shows along the way yeah and
you and you know some Ram Chase put on
the background and now it just seems
like every time I put on Netflix it's
just oh this is a background joke and
it's it's it's I never put on Netflix to
be like I'm going to commit to this
anymore
um I honestly just use Netflix to like
just watch like movies that I'm just
come out in the past where I'm just like
oh okay it's on Netflix I guess I'll
watch it while it's here but it's not
like something I'm like seeking out you
know it's not like I have to watch this
movie thank God it's on Netflix yeah I
mean I haven't watched the new glass uh
knives out yet but uh I heard that's
pretty good I I've watched it it's good
I heard that it was all like every story
first one was really good it's meant to
be self-contained yeah right
um and yeah I mean how to find time it's
it's it was like a kind of like a murder
mystery who'd done it and then it didn't
blow my mind away or anything like that
you know it was it was it was a fun time
we watched on Christmas Eve I think
right and it was like for some reason
even though it was set in like the
middle of like a like a [ __ ] summer
like Mr Beast Private Island kind of I
got two people on an island to solve
American mystery one of them is going to
die you know you know you know what I
remember watching knives out and I was
like this just feels like a Mr Beast
video that they've thrifted for for like
the longest time it didn't make the
YouTube
let's just give it let's just give it a
nail place
eventually killed Chandler and you have
to find out who did it
oh my God oh my God I mean yeah I mean I
think Netflix has really been struggling
for a while uh especially if you look at
uh the amount of shows they've canceled
yeah oh yeah the big meme is that they
just cancel every show that's remotely
interesting and good uh yeah they keep
pumping out 15 Adam Sandler movies
we definitely need those you know
apparently they do like in terms of
retention they're like one of the best
yeah people [ __ ] love Adam Sandler
movies to be fair I did watch click
while I was sick so well that's an older
one I like what's new about him I'd
never easy to watch yeah what is like
what is it like a new Adam Sandler film
because I feel like I haven't heard of
an Adam Sandler film they're like well
because they're all just kind of like
direct to Netflix kind of meh yeah it's
like the equivalent of like director DVD
right right they don't really get a
cinema theater release have you guys
watched any of the recent ones I watched
one of them that was a murder mystery
funny enough
comedy murder mystery with like I think
it was Jennifer Aniston and that oh that
one was really bad but I also didn't
like I think he's done a great job at
making everyone know his films suck but
we'll still watch them right because
you're kind of like oh I mean he's
harmless yeah it's like it's like
porridge you're like huh well I mean I
guess and I love it but I don't hate it
changed me for two hours I think that's
what's happening